what's happening I'm coming to you from
the beautiful Harvard Medical School in
Boston I arrived last night I've had the
requisite amount of caffeine and I'm
about to go and sit down with David
Sinclair who was a biologist and a
professor of genetics here at Harvard
Medical School you may have recognized
him from the Joe Rogan podcast he did a
couple of months ago that was
interesting and exciting to say the
least
introduce me to a lot of topics that I
didn't know about before I'm super
excited to follow up on some of them
today so yeah stay tuned professor David
Sinclair of Harvard Medical School how
are you today I'm doing really well boys
I'm very very glad to be here off to see
your friends at inside track it later on
I'm gonna go straight over there and
have a sit down with them and go through
my my results see what - see what
they've got to say
oh really you've had your blood drawn I
haven't go home it'll be exciting I went
to quest Diagnostics week in a bit ago
in California and I went through my
results with Stacey if it's not if she's
not called Stacey I'm gonna be in so
much bother with one of the analysts
inside tracker and they took me through
all of my stuff earlier on actually
which is super interesting
so are you older or younger than your
actual age I am 31 in real years and the
inside of my body is 36 oh that is
because glucose being out of range
weights very heavily and the only thing
I've got is slightly out of range
glucose and my lipids are a tiny little
bit out as well so I need to eat soluble
fiber
yeah you'll you'll enjoy that
soluble fiber when I was looking at the
list of potential groups of foods it was
just 20 different types of beans I was
like I have no I have no types of beans
in my diet like a baked beans like does
that count as a bean I'm sure it does it
has the desired effect I bet it's a
indeed so the first question I've got
for you what what do you do here I know
we're in Harvard Medical School I
haven't got the first idea about what it
is that you do well so I I come in
everyday to my lab there's about 30 to
35 people in my lab and I instruct them
to discover really cool stuff and that's
basically my job and they'll come to me
and they'll say I've got an idea to
discover something and I'll say that
sounds good go do it or that sounds
really boring don't bother doing it and
by the way how much is that gonna cost
and they'll tell me it's gonna cost
about two million dollars so it's my job
to bring in the money and let them
figure it out but the theme of my lab is
focused on aging and has been since I
started the lab about 20 years ago here
at Harvard and so I I run a center for
aging research here and we are really
working not just on trying to understand
why we age but also how do we slow down
and reverse that process as well and
that's all being conducted here but also
off site up one of your multiple
companies or is it mostly here or is it
how does it work well there's a giant
ecosystem this is the Menlo Park version
of the ecosystem where we do the very
basic discovery we can ask fundamental
questions about what is the clock of
aging can we reprogram the body is it
safe and can we extend lifespan mostly
of animals we work with here these are
laboratory animals outside of the
university is a network of companies
institutes colleagues collaborators
literally thousands of people around the
globe Europe Asia Australia and others
are all working with us on trying to
understand these questions answers to
these questions but also what makes my
lab rare and unusual is we're very
innovative so that we file patents once
every few months we spin out a company
at least a couple of times a year
and the reason for doing that is not
because well I do like starting
companies but that's not why I do it I
do it because I'm not satisfied with
just publishing work I feel that my role
on this planet if I have one is to try
and help people with their lives to live
longer and healthier and more
productively and just making a discovery
in a yeast cell or a mouse isn't doing
it for me that's just part of what I'm
here for
you need to apply that as well exactly
so most of the companies that come out
of this lab are biotech companies
working on medicines but we also do a
whole range of other things we have
biosecurity so protecting the world from
pathogens and and other nasty things
that can go on we also work on
bioinformatics so trying to understand
so like inside tracker how do you
estimate somebody's age and help them
with their living and what they're
eating but mostly it's molecules that we
hope will be drugs one day to not just
treat one particular disease of aging
say diabetes or heart disease or cancer
but to have a radical type of medicine
that would actually slow down all
diseases at once with a single pill is
it likely that there is a I don't know
where the policy is the right word but a
out there a particular way to manipulate
molecules which will be the equivalent
of an aging panacea well there certainly
will be a lot of people who here that
we're close to finding something that'll
slow down aging the right to be
skeptical because sounds like turning
back time right like literally feels
like are you slow down aging yet cooling
can I go and get in a DeLorean at the
same time please is that Alright right
but actually figuring out how to slow
down aging or reverse time is is a lot
easier than building a time machine and
I think it's going to be easier than
curing cancer it's not that hard we
actually understand as a field over the
last 20 years what controls aging we
have genes in our body called longevity
genes that slow the process down and in
recent breakthroughs just in the last
couple of years the field and my lab
have discovered that you can reprogram
the body and reset the body's clock to
be young again and when I say body I
mean it's still in in the lab but we
hope that within a couple of years we'll
be actually be doing human clinical
trials to literally reverse aging in
cells what's the mechanism that this
works on can you take us through yeah
well there are three main approaches
that we're taking and I'll just
summarize them the first that we've been
doing for a long time is activating the
body's defenses against aging so
normally you have to be hungry or
exercised to do that we've found genes
and molecules that you can give to
animals and enter people actually that
slow down the effects of aging so that's
one so that think of that is activating
the body's natural defenses against
deterioration and disease that would be
doing for 20 years at least the second
is to delete cells that are actually
causing the problem so there are cells
called senescence cells that you might
think of as zombie cells and those
zombie cells are causing havoc and you
can actually get rid of them and when
you do that in a mouse it'll live longer
and be healthier then the third approach
which is much more recent but much more
powerful than any of those is called
partial Saylor reprogramming and my lab
and some others have actually shown just
a few others around the world that
currently if you put a combination of
resetting genes into cells in the dish
and actually in an animal you can quite
literally reverse the age of those cells
so that they become young again and in
mice what we're discovering we're
writing these papers up now is that you
can drive aging forward and accelerate
it with this technology and you can
reverse it just as easily and make cells
behave as though they're almost
embryonic I'll give you an example
yes when we're when we're born one of
the first things that ages in our body
is a is our spinal cord and our central
nervous system and you you might say
well Dave why do you say it's aging well
a young neuron will be able to repair
itself and regrow but we know that if we
damage our IR optic nerve or our spine
we're never gonna walk again or see you
again
but if you're young or if you're a
salamander you can actually regrow than
the central nervous system so we've got
ways now of reprogramming those cells or
an entire Mouse to make it ostensibly
younger again and they regrow their
optic nerves so that they can see again
that sounds like science fiction I
thought so too but in May this past year
2018 one of my students who was working
on this one chain he thought it was
never going to work but he thought he
tried anyway so he injected this gene
combination into the eye of a mouse and
he damaged the optic nerve so that was
all dying turned on the system and it
grew back and he texted me the picture
and said I cannot believe this is
working and I said you know what I can
see the future right now and he since
tested it on glaucoma which is damaged
due to high pressure he's tested on on
just on regular old mice that don't have
good vision I'm almost 50 and I can
already tell my retinas not as good as
it used to be we can actually treat old
mice and get them to see like a young
mouse within just a few weeks I to me
aging feels a little bit like the
passage of time
so it feels like something that you are
along for the ride with and it would
appear that that's not quite the case
and that I think I'm a good avatar for
the layperson I understand that cells
regenerate and I think that your entire
body every cell is redone within a
particularly not a hugely long window of
time but for some reason the concept of
them actually growing or getting younger
just seems the odds it feels like we
would be going back in time well we're
going back in age and you can disconnect
biological age from chronological age
the one of the main reasons I believe we
age is that we have what's called an
epigenetic clock that ticks our
as we get older due to time but also how
we treat our bodies if we smoke we don't
exercise or we're obese the clock will
take faster but now that we understand
what the clock is we're finding that we
can actually revert that age and get the
biological clock to go back would not
just slow it down
and so those nerve cells that I was
talking about regenerating we do
literally make them biologically young
again and how that actually happens is
on the cutting edge of science right now
but we have some clues as to how the
cell is accessing the youthful
information that is locked away inside
it can you explain how that works I can
to the very extent of what is known to
the science right now yes and your best
your best idea is it what's on this
whiteboard is some of it that's a messy
diagram that I drew trying to explain it
it looks like bunches of grapes those
are some mice running towards other mice
that's a little boat at sea that is
that's a cloud that's a cloud with birds
coming out of it
it's exactly right you solved it cricket
balls yep yep actually that's a tennis
game within ourselves literally well
though and maybe not not literally you
don't have tennis balls but what we do
have are proteins that act like tennis
balls that bounce around inside the
cells going from one thing to another
and that's a tennis game and what we've
discovered is that normally those tennis
balls those proteins will sit on parts
of the genome to tell a cell it's a
liver cell or it's a brain cell muscle
cell so it doesn't regenerate the wrong
thing right okay right and those are lay
down those structures in the cells or
lay down when we're born so a muscle
cell is not going to give rise to two
Lua cells it's gonna give rise to more
muscle cells yes and we understand
pretty much how that works these
proteins that sit on the DNA they
control which genes are on and which are
off at any one time okay but those balls
actually get distracted and so that
here's where the tennis analogy comes in
we can distract those proteins by doing
things to the cell one really great way
of distracting them is to break a
chromosome and then those proteins they
panic and the cell pulls them to the
break to help repair the broken
chromosome leaving those genes
and to wreak havoc for a short period
but then once the repair is complete
they'll go back and re-establish that
program again so that the liver cell
stays a liver cell the problem is with
the tennis analogy if you keep whacking
balls back and forth over 70 or 80 years
you don't lose balls you're going to not
hit them back to where they came from
and it ends up being a huge mess and so
there's balls scattered all over the
court or in this case the those proteins
that were once laid down in the right
place to turn the cell the genes on at
the right time and now scattered all
over the the cell the nucleus and the
cell loses its identity so a liver cell
is an old liver cell is more like other
cells in the body and actually they
forget to be liver cells okay so can you
explain the difference between what
would look like a young Solomon would
look like an old cell or what is what
categorizes that that's someone who
needs to know what a young liver and an
old liver cell look like that's what the
person well I can pretty much guarantee
you that it's someone calling me to find
out how much of a certain molecule they
should ingest that's usually different
really what you're getting hundreds of
emails a day really it's a lot well I
mean this is the Joe Rogan effect isn't
it well it's always been a lot but yeah
Joe did increase the ladders of magnet
interests for sure
also fairly rare as a scientist I talk
about research as it's happening mm-hmm
and it's it sparked people's imagination
to Segway briefly here one of my friends
who spends a fair bit of time on reddit
mentioned that him and some of his
buddies loved the episode that you done
with Joe and that they were part of the
are slash longevity thread on reddit and
I just decided that he would post one of
my buddies who's currently going to a
podcast with Professor David Sinclair
does anyone have any questions and I
thought it would be like I don't know
how many how many pieces of fruit and
veg should I eat a day or how long is
the optimal window of a fast like you
know sixteen eight or should I be doing
like 18 six or whatever it might be and
the list of questions
that I had to try and translate I've not
even there in Evernote but they're just
staying there because I can't pronounce
half of the words that are in there but
I think one of the things that it
definitely did identify to me is that
longevity at the moment appears to be a
very emerging field within kind of the
general public or becoming more of a
general public concern I mean everyone's
aging right right well we've always been
aging as a species for ever since we
were you know primordial cells in the
soup or four billion years ago and we've
always been conscious of our mortality
but I think there are two things
happening because one is that the
science is mature and it's no longer an
if it's just a when we have the
technology we understand how to slow
down aging maybe even reverse it and the
other is that the world I see is
bifurcating into two types of people
those that want to understand a topic in
detail so that your listeners are those
type of people and God bless them this
is the level of detail that typically
members of the public wouldn't ever know
about and then the rest of the world
watches cats playing piano and stuff but
thank goodness there are people who
really care about the world and what's
happening and and want to learn in
detail beyond what typically a newspaper
used to tell people I agree I think that
we've they man spaded the ability for
people to to learn in as much detail as
they want and there is a there is a
horse for every course with regards to
what people want to learn you talk you
write that for myself i we get comments
all the time on the YouTube videos and
stuff like a to long didn't read like
can someone do a tldr of this particular
podcast and I'm like if you want a
shortened version of this there's
someone or if you want to watch
something which is short YouTube is
awash with three and four minute videos
like feel free to go and watch that I
particularly and I know that the
listeners do as well they enjoyed the
nuance and the subtlety in the detail
and and deconstructing things down to
its component parts over the course of
one two hours that's what I think is
important and it definitely sounds like
that's helping people to buy into more
difficult topics
potentially like this oh for sure
because when a newspaper reporter not
all of them but many of them over that
my career which now spends 2530 years
they latch onto this and it's always
hyped Oh we're gonna live forever you
should drink more red wine blah blah
blah and I can tell you as a scientist
who spent his career working on the
cutting edge of research at Harvard
Medical School publishing in the world's
best scientific journals it's really
frustrating and it's actually taken a
lot of willpower to make it through
those times because the know almost
every time what I say comes out changed
and you can save a nice version of
whatever it is that you've said and no
wonder the public says yeah this is
another stupid story it can't be true
but if you listen to two hours of
someone like me talking you really do
realize that the science is way more
advanced than people ever knew about and
as a scientist I just you know thank
heaven thank people like you who can
actually allow people like me to to
reach many people at a level that never
was possible before I totally agree um
how much this is a question that's been
percolating around in my head how much
do you think the increasing interest in
longevity with the general public is due
to a fear of death uh probably most of
it most of a deep down I think we're all
afraid of dying and maybe not that
actually the day we die we're not afraid
all I'm not afraid of dying of looked
death in the face a few times in my life
it's not that scary but I think we're
all fearful of of not being around it's
gonna be pretty boring we're never
probably never going to see our loved
ones again or our friends that's pretty
sad if you really think about it and it
actually takes a lot of courage to think
about our own mortality mostly by the
time we're 86 we forget about it and
don't think about it again till or about
50 years old and that interim period we
assume we're immortal of course we're
not and I don't think we ever will be
but I think what's going on is that that
once you realize that something can be
treated potentially then it gets
exciting a hundred years ago people used
to say
you know cancer and gangrene dying from
a splinter it's childbirth these were
things that were just the way life is or
was just the way it goes and so people
didn't really care that much about it
once antibiotics would develop to other
medical treatments people actually were
okay talking about it and the same is
happening with aging right now the best
analogy I could give in terms of human
history it's like the Wright brothers
were in 1902 they built their Wright
flyers and we're strapping on engines
and seeing where we can fly yeah you are
right that the frame is moving with
regards to the fidelity in the
resolution with which we see life that a
splinter could have killed you 100 years
ago or that I've read an article not too
long ago about the fact that so many
prehistoric people died from issues with
their teeth that they had mouth
infections that was one of the one of
the main things because they had no way
to be able to comprehensively clean the
their mouths and you are right as as
time begins to move forward and as the
public perception hasn't yet caught up
with the technology that's available the
status quo as it is at the moment while
aging is always going to be there we've
always got Holdren now we we will
forevermore was the same as 100 years
ago people have always died in
childbirth or people have always died
from gangrene or a splint or a scurvy or
whatever it might be exactly that's
exactly right and that's why I think
that especially younger people who tend
to listen to this kind of show more than
older people really get it they get that
we're going through a scientific
transformation and that the future that
most people think is coming that's not
going to happen the future is something
quite different and people who are born
today or people in their 20s and 30s are
going to see radical changes that are
far bigger and far more important than
the iPhone you know does anyone really
care about the next you know additional
memory in an iPhone I think we reached a
point where all of that technology
frankly is is being you know quite
disappointing with the new releases I'd
agree so what's the next big thing
females for Humanity well some of its
artificial intelligence I just had
one of the world's leading AI people
visit the lab this morning just that was
one of the reasons Wow
so that was the reason that we were
running half an hour late time if it if
he loved Musk's in here then it's fine
like elan may i'll forgive you
i would like to test the roadster please
if it's available but yeah it's okay
well yeah I agree with elan about a lot
of things but on AI I think he's wrong
I think that we can build AI systems and
enough checks that we will not be
overrun by evil have you read super
intelligence by Nick Bostrom not yet
it's a good highly highly recommended
you know Nick is prefer the head of the
future of humanities Institute where is
that over in London it's Kirk I think
it's Oxford Oxford University he's
recently do a podcast with Sam Harris
which is absolutely fantastic okay I
would recommend check now it will be in
the show not to below for anyone who
wants to to find out what I'm talking
about I don't want to Segway on her a I
but we've touched on it so I'm going to
do anyway the control problem for AI is
something that's difficult I think not
allowing our creations to get out of
hand is there a similar concern with
regards to developing these tools for
longevity that you could nefarious group
could get ahold of the technology and
then weaponize it or do something really
really sort of untoward well yeah always
you can turn technology against humanity
I'm not worried about that so much with
what I do because even though we have
the technology to make mice and probably
people aged rapidly
it'll be about the slowest way to damage
your enemies there are much more if you
shooting someone in the head is all has
been created it's a pretty efficient way
to there's there's that and somewhere in
between you know we could pretty easily
unleash a deadly virus that wouldn't be
too far beyond what we could even do in
this lab not that we would but yeah but
in terms of making people age
prematurely we shouldn't let me do it
and I could take you downstairs
or maybe somewhere I shouldn't say and
there if there are mice that we can
control their aging process forward and
backwards so that's doable um where I
think people get uncomfortable with this
technology is so we now understand that
there are genes that control how long we
live there's one for example called FOXO
which is turned on in wales and longer
lived animals than us
there are even human variants my
children were lucky enough to of them
out of three to inherit two really good
copies of this longevity gene and so
they're probably going to live a lot
longer than my wife and I will um so we
we know a lot about that so why does
this get weird well now that we can
CRISPR engineer babies what's gonna
happen when the world's most intent
helicopter parent wants a kid that can
live 220 that's probably doable right
now whether or not we should is another
question whose job is it to work out
whether or not we should well right now
there's a worldwide debate among
scientists about whether we should come
out against it interestingly when when
human stem cells were first discovered
and that you could reprogram cells and
clone animals there was a much greater
backlash you probably remember the the
Blair Bush days where there were all
these and these committees set up and it
was banned here in the US but we had
something just as big happen last year
was that the Chinese researcher
professor he had a couple of well
engineered a couple of twins twin girls
who were resistant going to be resistant
to HIV infection and he and you know
engineered those genetically now there
was a little bit of upset a lot of
scientists got upset because this was
announced without any warning at a
scientific conference there was no
oversight there was no consultation with
governments or other scientists so the
shock really took us all by surprise but
there was no major backlash there hasn't
been yet there hasn't been any outlawing
you certainly don't hear a lot of
backlash at the higher levels of
government over here in the US at least
um I think that's healthy I think that
what we've got is a
rational debate and that we shouldn't
just overreact just because something
feels weird
or isn't has never been done before now
we need to discuss
not just the ethics but is it safe and
that I think safety is more important
than than ethics actually and what I
mean by that is someone's ethics might
be different than yours I mean usually I
come down on the side of freedom to do
things as long as they're safe and that
they're beneficial and there's some
consent but in this case what's tricky
is that your children don't have consent
so that's why I think it's it's a hard
one but what if your child was
definitely going to get say a dominant
genetic disease and there was no way to
get around it except either have new
parents or don't breed or to have an
abortion what would be an example of a
dominant genetic disease so Huntington's
for example if both parents have
Huntington's you can or even one you can
have a a child with Huntington's I mean
you can always select the embryo but
maybe you don't want to kill embryos so
maybe you could create an embryo that
you go in with this CRISPR editing
system and chop out the bad Huntington's
gene and create healthy child that
should be doable it's a big ethical
question there isn't that well there
there is though if you're making people
healthier and not suffer and I always
say that that's what we humans have
always done that's why we invented
aspirin and antibiotics we're just going
into a new era where we can really have
a big effect because it's not just on
one person's life
it's generations forever beyond that
person what's the second order third
order fourth order effect of this
particular decision yeah I guess the the
more subtle the muscle question is
between Huntington's disease and a
healthy human baby the line appears to
be quite clear as why is preferable but
as the fidelity of that becomes while
I've got to ginger parents and my dad
got bullied at school for being ginger
like
I don't want to have a ginger child you
know where do we begin to draw the line
here because in essence all we're
talking about the lowest or the highest
resolution is preference it is and then
it gets really crazy when parents say I
want the smartest kid I can have or the
best-looking kid can we identify the
contributing factors to that well there
there was a gene published last year
that is thought to contribute it to
human intelligence and speech the
differential differentiates us from the
chimps and perhaps having more copies of
that gene could make us smarter we don't
know that yet so I think that that's
still in science realm of science
fiction but you know looking ahead 30
years from now you could probably
engineer your child to have these traits
love suddenly hide disease resistance we
can protect against cardiovascular
disease and what about intelligence for
longevity and then we also it gets into
a crazy zone where imagine 100 years
from now that you can have an army of
clones or of people who are robust who
heal better don't bleed out diseases
yeah I mean this is not beyond
possibility in terms of technology today
and here in the second decade of the
21st century 22nd century it's going to
be quite something to see in biology
getting back to the iPhone
I think biology is gonna really make a
much bigger difference to our lives than
any electronic we have energy yeah I'll
do live Wikipedia did you listen to Alex
Jones on Joe Rogan the most recent one I
did yeah I mean I don't really even know
where to start with that but the the
trans human animal hybrids and the flesh
farms wherever it is like is is that the
sort of thing that's doable at the
moment with current technology oh yeah
we do create comic chimeric animals in
the lab yeah and so that what they are
going to find among chimeric well it's a
it's a an organism that's comprised of
cells with different genomes
and so it's a mixed organism and yeah we
could do that but I mean that that to me
seems highly unethical and even
unnecessary well I think everyone would
would agree if that's the case but it
doesn't necessarily stop the technology
from occurring and I suppose the line
between how do you what if you had to do
a lot of iterations of chimera
proliferation and X number of years from
then you would develop this unbelievable
new solution to something you've been
looking to work on does the costs
outweigh the benefit right well I think
we all we all have personal views on
that one area that I think is really
interesting in this building right here
at Harvard Medical School is whether or
not you think it's okay to use animal
organs for humans and so one of the
reasons we don't use Pig livers for
transplant is they're full of Pig
viruses but George Church and his
spin-out company are actually removing
those viruses cutting them out of the
pig genome so that these livers might be
useful and you might say well we we
shouldn't be breeding pigs to have
transplants but if we're eating the rest
of the animal and throwing away the
livers why not that's a very good
question I'll be interested to hear what
the listeners think about that
particular ethical dilemma about I
suppose the vegans and the vegetarians
might be firmly on one side of that
already they don't need it doesn't
matter whether or not the livers going
into someone's body I think that they've
already made their stance on that yeah I
would charge the the listeners with the
following thought what if it was your
mother or your child who needed a liver
transplant and there were none available
would you sacrifice a pig that's a
difficult question to answer is No
mm-hmm so moving back onto the questions
that you get all of the time ringing
through the phone what are the
what would you say are the foundational
strategies that people right now should
be looking to incorporate into their
lives to improve longevity all right
well one of the the reasons that this
field is is taking off also is because
there are things that people can do
right now that we've learned are
actually helpful for turning on these
longevity genetic pathways if I could
give one piece of advice only one and I
will give more but if I could only give
one the most important thing would be
eat less eating less has been shown for
four centuries but also in labs for the
last 70 80 years to be extremely
effective in extending lifespan of
everything from yeast cells to worms to
flies to my stomach ease and if humans
don't live longer for fasting and
calorie restriction then then we'd be
the exception on the planet and I don't
believe that were an exceptional species
biologically speaking so eat less what
does that mean well nobody knows what
the perfect diet is I get a lot of those
questions what should i eat what should
i well what you eat is important but
when you eat and how much you eat are
just as important as well so what and I
give you an example what I do as you
know I do a bit of research and I've
come up with my own best practices so I
do intermittent fasting now there are a
variety of those and I think many of
your listeners probably know them by
name but there is fast every other day
there's fast two days out of five is
skip breakfast and perhaps have a late
lunch and don't have a late dinner as
well that's the one that I prefer I find
it easier to skip breakfast and have a
late lunch
than to really go through days of of
being hungry I can't tolerate it for too
long but I don't mind hunger pains for a
few hours on top of that I take a drug
called metformin which is prescribed for
debate diabetics type 2 diabetics age
associated diabetes which has two main
effects first of all obviously it blows
blood glucose that's what it's
prescribed for for for patients but it
also is quite rough on people's stomach
and I find that it actually stopped me
from being
we curb the hunger pangs yeah it really
is effective and so I have the kind of
biology and so does my son that we like
to eat we feel hunger more strongly
apparently than other people with kind
of like Labradors of the human world but
we also gain weight rapidly we put on
muscle we also gain weight pretty
quickly and so I would if I was allowed
to eat what I wanted to without a lot of
mental power and a little bit of help
from their Foreman I would be quite an
obese person and and my son god bless
him I he hopefully he's not listening to
his podcast he's put on a lot of weight
he's 11 years old and we going to the
gym but you can see that it's pretty
hard for people with our genotype to
keep the weight off and so body is
wearing it the chomping at the bit to
get bigger well it is it is and so he's
getting strong but he's also covered in
a layer of fat and so my point is that
if I can do it and you know I've got a
BMI about 21 22 if I can do it anyone
can because you are genetically
predisposed to have a poor thin person
body type yeah well you know my father
it was prone to obesity his diet has
diabetes and his grandmother well my
grandmother his mother had a stroke in
their 30s and had type 2 diabetes
something like I've half Eskenazi Jew
genetics and coming out of Hungary
Sinclair is not my real family name it's
Szigeti those genes are pretty crap when
it comes to longevity and so we're
fighting it
my main father my son myself trying to
live at least a normal lifespan I
understand so you mentioned that fasting
is effective due to calorie restriction
what's the mechanism that that works
right so we didn't know how calorie
restriction worked until recently and
it's exciting we understand it so how
does it work well this is partly what
we've discovered in my lab so many
others in the world as well but we can
put a little brick in the wall for that
we showed that there are longevity genes
they've got the name sirtuin actually
named after a yeast gene called so2 and
that gene controls which genes are
switched on and which genes are switched
off
it's called a silent information
regulator that's what sir two stands for
and this gene really gets back to that
clock of aging that I started talking
about earlier it controls which genes
should be off to maintain youth but over
time it actually gets distracted and
goes to other places to repair broken
chromosomes for example and ends up
causing a yeast cell to lose its
identity it actually loses its sexual
identity becomes sterile and that's a
hallmark of yeast aging so what that
tells us is that there are genes in a
yeast cell that control its longevity
turns out if you give a yeast cell moss
or two genes or more copies of so2 it'll
live longer
take it away it'll live shorter okay so
that's the fundamental knowledge that
you need to understand what I'm about to
tell you sir - makes a protein that
controls these the epigenome of these
genes but it doesn't work well unless it
has an molecule in the cell called nad
the long term the long word for that is
nicotinamide adenine dinucleotide but
let's call it any one eight days much
better yeah yeah any D or nad some
people call it should be called nad not
don't call it mad I'm British and nads
are not not what I want to be taking
know we want larger nads that's we we
have we have nabbed boosters in the lab
that's what that's what my dad takes so
these net nad boosters the relevance of
that is that these surtout proteins this
fortuyn's in in our body they don't work
well unless they have a lot of nad in
the cell as we get older and even as
yeast cells get older they lose their
nad so that by the time you have 50
years old like me you have about half
the levels of nad that you had when you
were 20 without the nad the sirtuins are
lazy they don't control the genes of
youth well and they don't repair broken
DNA well and that leads to aging in
organisms we believe among other things
but that's one of the main causes so
what is calorie restriction and fasting
you have to do with it by fasting and
calorie strict in we actually boost the
level
of nad in the cell so that those repair
genes and those protectors of the of the
genome so Chileans are more active
that's one of the explanations for
calorie restriction there are other
genes that control aging is one called
mTOR there's one called NP kinase and
all of these longevity pathways that I'm
telling you about are boosted by fasting
and so we think that by being hungry
what you're really doing in a general
sense is telling the body I'm under
threat I might be dead in a month from
now my food supply is running out I'm
gonna hunker down I'm gonna build a
stronger body I'm gonna survive I'm
gonna breathe less remember the yeast
cells become sterile we become less
fertile if we're starving as well by the
way especially women um and that's a
survival response that we kick into
action just by being hungry or by
exercising for that matter is that one
of the reasons why bodybuilders when
they died down for a show and they're a
super low body fat will have trouble
with maintaining erections and sex drive
and things like that is that likely to
be the same pathway well so I didn't
know that for a fact but it perfectly
makes sense that it's a balance between
growth and reproduction and hunkering
down and surviving and we call this the
disposable soma theory so this is
actually a hybrid Tom Kirkwood just
proposed this back in the 1970s and the
idea is that species as a whole and
individuals also are exercising a
trade-off between growing fast and
reproducing and hunkering down and
building a body that lasts a long time
so by stimulating growth and
reproduction so if you take a lot of
testosterone that triggers a lot of
growth take a lot of protein amino acids
it's great body building you'll repair
things better but it's probably at the
expense of building a long lasting body
eventually that may run out so you might
want to pulse between growth rate
reduction and then shut it down a little
bit by fasting and so testosterone is
one of those molecules that tells the
body grow muscle which is shut down by
being hungry so you'd survive
so the the actual hunger itself is it
the sensation of being hungry that
causes this beneficial effect or is it
the fact that the blood glucose is lower
is it what the actual mechanism that
it's working well it's actually thought
to be both based on Mouse experiments if
you cut back on calories but still fill
the stomach with cellulose that is
sufficient to extend lifespan so part of
it is the the biochemical response to
low calories and low amino acid okay but
it's not everything so that you can be
full and you can still get the benefits
of low calories that's interesting but
on the other hand some people have done
the opposite which is give a lot of
calories but simulate hunger and you can
do that by tweaking the brain and
amazing increasing ghrelin release and
stuff like that exactly and people can
also tweak the hypothalamus which in
itself can extend the life span of an
atom I mean tweaking the hypothalamus
sounds like a terrifying thing to do
it's not taking your car in to get the
MRT don't have a service it's like
poking your brain right it's changing
glucocorticoids which signal to the body
that it's hungry or it needs to grow and
that also extends lifespan does anything
not extend lifespan because I'm learning
things I feel like I feel like
everything that we've talked about today
I just live to 120 just by pretending
just testing stuff I'll open that drawer
I'll see if that drawer extends lifespan
I like useless use my left hand to put
that coat on that'll extend life as well
obviously we don't we don't read about
those studies that failed yes so there's
a lot of things in my lab for example
that never extended lifespan and there
any notable examples of that that you
thought or was there anything that you
thought would really was a real winner
and then it turned out to not be a
winner well let's see so usually we
don't embark on a mouse experiment
that'll take three or four years without
some pretty good science behind it
we tried some plant molecules that
didn't it's down
the lifespan of some some species gee
let me think we we tried some versions
of rapamycin which are turned down this
mTOR pathway one of those longevity
pathways and that didn't extend yeast
cells very much because we think there
was some side effects of toxicity let's
see oh we over expressed the cert one
gene one of these mammalian so
children's and that didn't work when we
figured out why turns out that in the
brain sort of one actually has a
negative impact in the pituitary we
haven't published this yet but even
though sort one made it robust Mouse and
it was protected against pretty much all
diseases we could give it diabetes and
heart disease it didn't live longer and
we found out because in the pituitary it
needs to be off rather than on ah so
you've got this physically incredibly
robust Mouse but it's actually suffering
with dementia and it's like super old
and super wise well what happens with
the pituitary is it controls growth
hormone yep and so what by turning it
down in the pituitary rather than up we
actually it created small mice that
lived a long time if we just tweaked it
in that part of the body but by turning
it on in the whole animal that turning
it on in and gave the mouse a lot of
growth hormone so we had a bigger more
robust Mouse but it didn't live longer
unfortunately you took shun growth home
on there I remember watching bigger
stronger faster Chris bells documentary
a long time ago where he was talking
about recreational steroid use in
America and said that amongst that one
of the commonly used compounds is human
growth hormone the UK is very different
to the way that it is out here in terms
of getting a prescription from your
doctor and all that sort of stuff one of
the places that he went to is an
anti-aging convention and he made a joke
about the being loads of old people
there walking around and pretty much
every single stall was offering human
growth hormone I think exogenous human
growth hormone as a
a solution right what's the truth in
that if there is any well I don't think
there's any evidence in humans that it
extends the lifespan growth hormone
Allah shorten well that's the debate now
it's really not known anyone who says
they know the answer it really doesn't
doesn't know what they're talking about
but theoretically it could it could
shorten lifespan for a couple of reasons
one is so testosterone and growth
hormone could make pre-existing tumors
grow faster potentially but there been a
lot of studies where it's seemingly safe
at least over the course of a year or
two and so I think that I hate to say
this because we all want perfect answers
but the jury's still out about the
long-term safety
I think replenishing testosterone and
growth hormone to levels that are
natural in in young people I think
should be okay that's my personal view
testosterone has been studied quite a
lot in the elderly and even though there
were some benefits in terms of strength
and muscle maintenance there was
apparently no change in mortality so we
need to do more than just raise
testosterone I believe interesting I
guess there's a balance as well between
quality and length of life as well that
you potentially take something which may
shorten your life but if it only reduces
your life by 5%
but doubles your mobility your quality
of life however it may be I suppose that
there's a very big balancing act that
you guys constantly need to play when
you're looking at these well it's not as
hard as you might think by turning on
these or two and jeans and changing mTOR
and the same thing kinase this metformin
pathway we actually find that we
lengthen the health span all the animals
and so what that means is they don't get
cancer heart disease Alzheimer's
diabetes until much later in their life
that's why we call it the health span
and you know what happens when animals
don't get sick they live longer
that's a nice side effect right animals
don't die if they're healthy same with
humans and so it hasn't been a hard
thing to balance in fact if you focus on
health span life span is a nice
byproduct of that
that's a very good way to look at it so
you've mentioned fasting would appear to
be the the Perrine or the 8020 of what
we're looking at here for the vast
majority of people it's free I mean say
it's actually better than free like it's
cheaper than what you're doing at the
moment what else would you as a
disclaimer we are not your doctor this
is not medical advice please seek a
physician etc etc disclaimer disclaimer
what else do you think is an optimal
strategy that some people if they chose
to would be able to undertake sure well
what I do is I
besides implement fasting I also
exercise exercises the other thing that
raises nad and who's these longevity
pathways and we've also known for
centuries that this is healthy right so
we're not discovering anything that new
other than what types of exercise seem
to activate these longevity pathways the
best and what seems to work best is the
high intensity interval training is to
get the body stressed so just as
intermittent fasting tricks the body
into thinking your food running out
exercises tricking the body into
thinking I might have to run a marathon
or yeah that exactly there's a
saber-toothed tiger in town okay so that
that's exactly right so the the
high-intensity seems to really stimulate
the body's defense networks even more
than just a a long walk or or a steady
long run it's all about varying it right
the high the low so intermittent fasting
it's it's food no food and intensity
training is running stop running stop
hypoxia oxygen hypoxia and it's that up
and down that seems to work really well
that's why whatever you're doing do
something different and get your body
into shock so the thing to think about
is the concept is called hormesis but
really the concept of hormesis is just
whatever doesn't kill you makes you
stronger and longer live by the way so
keep your body on edge it sounds like
all of the things that are good for you
are really uncomfortable
or a lot of the things that yet for you
well that's the say I think people say
oh why is cake taste so why does it
taste so
and why doesn't Sydney on the couch feel
good no other way around why doesn't
exercise feel good and why is sitting on
the couch bad for you I mean that's
exactly the reason is that you've got to
put your body in the this slight painful
experience to get it to react otherwise
it becomes complacent anybody just falls
apart it would be nice if cake X
identity life it wouldn't it it would be
fantastic if that was the case um what
else what else is that big you're doing
what else well so I mentioned med form
and that's been a recent change is that
siliceous some of this is available
without prescription but I think
metformin is something which you do need
a prescription for is that right in
Western countries yeah in Eastern
countries less so the common well yes
okay everything in Thailand over the
camp yeah you can and actually it's
smart of them I think because they have
rampant diabetes like we do and
metformin is one of the safest drugs in
the world you get an upset stomach
extremely rare that there's anything
more serious than that it's not
perfectly safe no drug is but in terms
of drugs this one's pretty safe it's a
derivative of molecule from the French
lilac it's an basically a version of a
pliant molecule so anyway so I take Mike
Foreman every morning sometimes I vary
it you know I'm not strict with
everything but sometimes it's half a
gram sometimes it's a gram a typical
diabetic will take somewhere between a
gram and two grams so it's bit below
that what else do I do let's get this
all on the table throw it out there come
on right again disclaimer I'm not
recommending is waiting to find out what
you do well no I don't know if I'm gonna
live longer I'm I'm 50 if you can judge
how am i doing you look fantastic
don't listen to well see to let me know
if I have a gray hair that's been one
thing I guess going all right yeah
anyway okay so let's lay it out so an
nad booster yep how much I take a a gram
of an nad booster every morning and it's
water so you also just take it with a
drink with a coffee along with the
metformin I also take
grandma resveratrol which isn't a strict
amount I actually just shake some powder
into yogurt and mix it up a few spoons
of yogurt I've also been asked over the
internet on Twitter that asked don't you
think that that's breaking the fast it's
no longer fasting like I thought you
said Sinclair dude yeah well it's not
actually you Lou has ruined well I don't
regard that as as a lot of calories I
actually make my own yogurt it's a it's
one made out of special bacteria are you
considering marketing I bet people buy
if you if you released well by yogurts
it's not mine
it's actually commercially available
okay what where well I don't know the
people who make it so this is not an
endorsement but it's called Bravo and I
know it's in America and Europe okay but
it works out great I don't follow the
instructions I just get full cream milk
I get a jar about that big and I just
pour it all in shake it up put it in the
oven on defrost or whatever it is yes
yeah its body temperature leave it for
about 24 hours and it's beautiful thick
yogurt and for breakfast I take a couple
spoonfuls
I'm gonna guess I'm probably not super
calorie dense anyway probably is - full
fat yogurt full fat milk though like
yeah how would you have it maybe a big
bowl well I make it anywhere are that
how much you eat two spoonfuls two or
three it's not not breaking the fast I
think they say is you breaking the fast
Christie thank you they leave the room
don't worry um so what else you do
whilst you do your exercising you're
fasting you have your NID got your
resveratrol you've got your met form
right is that it's that's the main thing
I mean um my doctor gives gives me a
statin because I've had high cholesterol
since I was in my 20s so that's another
you know thanks Jewish genes I'm kind of
screwed there um I take a still take a
baby aspirin a day even though that baby
aspirin well it's it's anyone milligrams
of aspirin okay what's that for blood
thinning right right and the the current
recommendation in general from the
Medical Association just so we're clear
I'm not a doctor but I read the
literature is that if you haven't had a
heart attack
maybe maybe No
take it I haven't had a heart attack yet
but I'm I'm convinced that it will help
with my blood flow gosh I hope not that
would be a bad look that would be a
remaini bad luck wouldn't it yeah um one
question that did come out of the reddit
funeral which I think was actually
pretty pertinent was when do you think
that people should begin thinking about
longevity obviously we think about
health our whole lives like we don't
just let the kids go loose on the butt
like a bag of sugar but is there you
know should people be taking nad at 18
years old I love that question because I
have new answers to that based on new
research partly in this lab unleash it
unleash it on the world so heating here
is something that almost no scientists
let alone in the public understands the
clock of Aging the epigenetic clock that
we measure and other scientists have
published now just a few months ago
begins even before birth we are aging
constantly [ __ ] yep
and it actually tracks with development
girls who go through puberty early have
a faster aging clock so older they're
older they're literally older so even
though you think you look old you're
actually getting older and you might age
faster than others it'll show up later
in your life but it's pretty scary right
so the other thing that we know is that
if your mother while you're in her
uterus ate certain foods you can be
predisposed either to obesity and
diabetes or to health and longer life
which is crazy so you might one answer
could be the earlier the better even
before you're born you should be working
on this Yeah right if you've got you
know helicopter parents he'll
genetically engineer you and feed you
the right food in any way but I the
other the other answer is this is a
really important one is that in in
animal studies in Mouse studies
particularly the earlier we start after
development of course we're not going to
calorie restrict or interfere with these
pathways before an animal reaches
adulthood let alone a person but
after adulthood st. 2425 equivalent of a
mouse we put them on these regimes of
molecules or genes and that's we get the
biggest bang for your buck starter early
if we start midlife let's say on a 50
year-old equivalent of a mouse you get
about half the effect of when you start
early and that's why actually I mean I
started way early compared to my peers
my scientific peers I started
resveratrol when I was in my early 30s
and I probably would have started early
and knowing now like if I knew then what
I know now I guess when you're talking
maybe 10 20 years ago it's this
experimental drug no one really knows
what the effects are and you're just
like [ __ ] it might make me live longer I
better just take it like something like
big risk to take
well it wasn't that risky we had fed it
to mice I knew that it didn't kill them
and it was in red wine so I was just
taking an overdose of the red wine
molecule but I'm prepared to to die for
my science I've never said that publicly
but I believed so strongly in what I do
and the benefits for Humanity if I had
died I would have been pissed off but I
would have would have sucked yeah but
but I I did it knowing that there were
risks and everybody who's listening
should know that what I'm saying I do
comes with risks right I don't know if
this gene of this molecule combination
with exercise and all this is shortening
my lifespan so far it's okay I'm not
dead yet my cardiovascular system and
everything else that's been measured
comes out pretty healthy but there are
risks and especially when I was in my
30s it could have been toxic over 20
years or even toxic for a few months but
I didn't I wasn't scared of the
consequences I was more scared of not
knowing than actually finding out the
truth well that's the true
inquisitiveness and I guess the
exploratory nature of someone who is a
scientist at the kind of the cutting
edge of this sort of stuff one of my
favorite podcasts that's ever been done
is Matthew Walker the guy who wrote why
we sleep on Joe Rogan and I think that
the topics that particularly resonate
with people are the ones that
the broadest cross-section of people can
relate to everybody sleeps
everybody is aging and I think that
that's one of the reasons why there is
such a such an interest in this
particular subject I
I was totally unexplored
before your podcast with Joe and I'm
super excited now knowing about this
whole new subdivision of science that I
didn't really even know was was this big
I'm super excited to see what happens
the same way as I read super
intelligence by Nick Bostrom and now I
want to know I'm super excited to see
what happens I'm terrified about what
might happen with AI and it's the same
for that I'm do you feel like a very in
a very fortunate position to be happier
finger in so many different longevity
pies yes there's no question that I wake
up every day and most days I pinch
myself that I'm in this position it
hasn't been easy and it's been not just
hard work I don't mind working hard I
love what I do but it's been there's
been criticism there's been ups and
downs getting there was maybe a bankrupt
company at one point wasn't doing he
took a big risk at some point I thought
it was it oh sure I mean there's there's
been so many thing so I've helped build
about 15 companies and they all go
through strife and running out of money
and a lot most of the money that I make
I pour back into companies you know it
made more money than I would ever know
what to do with but what I want to do
with that is is pour it back in and so
my wife chews her fingernails because
you know we're multi multi millionaires
for about a month until I find a way get
rid of it I don't want the money I want
to see that humanity progresses I want
to see what the future holds I wants to
get to the future faster and that's my
way of doing it but anyway the adversity
all scientists get criticized if they
stick their neck out to do something
that's different
whether it's discovering a longevity
gene or saying that we could live longer
or saying that aging is a disease
which I truly believe it is all of those
things have been tough but fortunately
I'm very stubborn and I'm not taking my
eye off of the prize in the end which is
that we all get to live hopefully all of
us get to live longer more productive
lives and when we do that we'll look
back at today and think what were we
thinking why weren't we doing a
Manhattan Project or baby maybe I should
call it a moonshot on this because it's
so important one of the things I truly
believe is that we look at all the
problems on the planet its global
warming there's poverty there's
bankruptcy for countries or at least
economic burden of people being sick all
of these are real problems social
security welfare in around the world I
think the biggest solution to that and
admittedly I'm somewhat biased but I do
crunch the numbers on this is if we can
solve people's health and make them more
productive for another 10 years maybe
even longer but 10 years would be enough
to save trillions of dollars every year
across the planet even in the US and
would be a saving in the tens of
trillions of dollars this is money that
can be put to work saving the economy
and working on other big problems that
we need to solve like the saving the
environment saving species preventing
global warming would it be an issue of
overpopulation with the yeah good
question it there's no question that if
people aren't dying as fast as they they
would there will be more people but it's
not as many as you might think if we
stopped everybody dying today in which
we can't do that but if nobody died
again the rate of population growth
would be less than the rate of
immigration here in the US which the
government's trying to limit that as
well yeah but it's it's not as though
suddenly there's there's five times as
many people and the good news is that
we're not going to stop aging anytime
soon we're just going to hopefully live
another five to ten years what that
means is though that we'll probably
plateau around ten billion maybe up to
thirteen billion but most of that
problem is not driven by people living
longer it's driven by the birthrate and
over the last decade we've seen an
extraordinary change in our birthrate
as a species and it's going down all the
time and going to Plateau the World
Health Organization and the UN have
agreed and Bill Gates has given a
wonderful podcast on this they were
gonna plateau out over the next 30 years
and we're not going to be overrun with
humans in fact places like Europe and
Asia are especially Japan are struggling
with not enough babies exactly more
humans but what you want to do is also
preserve the productivity of the older
people so when we look at a
seven-year-old now we think that's an
old person 10 years from now 20 years
from now 70 will be middle-aged or we
certainly see that happening already
look at Tom Cruise's what's he now and
his mid-fifties is riding motorcycles in
five and he looks great fantastic right
Top Gun and I couldn't agree more that
that was the question that I wanted to
finish on was well two parts firstly
would it be possible to make someone
live for a really inordinate amount of
time like a thousand years it's not
possible presuming they don't you know
get shot off one of the easier ways of
of killing someone that we identified
earlier on is though if they're a
realistic upper limit on the amount of
time that organism could live well we
know that there there isn't there are
immortal organisms on the planet there
are trees that live for thousands of
years there are jellyfish that go on
Hydra these little jellyfish like things
they live for seemingly more in what go
for immortality that the mistake that
that most people have is that they think
that there is a biological limit to
humans and they look at human history
and they say looking back in time
there's never been any one who as far as
we know has lived beyond 122 and even
that's doubtful that's been that's being
challenged I was in the Guinness Book of
World Records store on Hollywood
Boulevard a couple of days ago and they
had the photo of the guy that was 120
that was the oldest certified I think
but I mean I'm going to guess that the
standards to which you hold your
research may be a little bit higher than
that that the Guinness Book of Records
does well whether or not the gen carmine
france lived on
20 unknown odd doesn't matter there was
still plenty of people who make it 215
117 so let's say that's the the current
limit but looking backwards doesn't tell
you the future when it comes to
technology or when you looked at the
Wright brothers looking backwards from
1902 doesn't really tell you that we're
going to go to the moon within 60 years
so that actually happened so what I I
think is that there is no biological
limit to human lifespan we are living
things we fix ourselves we repair
ourselves we succumb to entropy no
question we lose information over time
but what we've discovered with this
reprogramming stuff is that we can
regain information that is still there
as we get older we just need to access
it those genes are still there to make
us young we just need to tell the cell
to read the right genes at the right
time and we can reverse aging and we
don't know how many times you can
reverse aging but it's possible you
could so let me tell you a bit of a
story but it's based on results in the
lab you know how I was telling you we
can reprogram neurons to grow again we
can actually use that same virus to
infect an entire Mouse and turn on these
reprogramming genes and get the mouse we
think to be younger that's what we're
working on
so we'll imagine a future where you
could have your genome changed so that
you have these reprogramming factors
injected so come along Chris today we
can go to my lab if we wanted to
literally I could take a vial of the
virus I could get give you an injection
and it would be compatible with your
body and you would be genetically
modified to be able to be reprogrammed
now we've engineered that virus
literally we have done this to be turned
on by an antibiotic called doxycycline
which you can go get from your doctor
I've been on it for a while I've been on
and off it for the last few years yeah
it's used as a doctor tetracycline is
used as a acne drug yes or anti malarial
or if you have Lyme disease here in the
u.s. it's pretty safe I mean you
wouldn't tell you don't accidentally
take that when you've got this super
gene that's potentially active inside
well so here's the thing we imagine a
future where you now have this virus in
your body and it switched off
you've nothing's happening to you but
you start to experience aging let's say
you're starting to build up
cardiovascular disease and your veins or
you're losing your memory how about you
just take antibiotic for a few weeks
you're reprogramming factors come on
your body gets rejuvenated it finds the
youthful information your nerve cells
remember how to you know have cells
again and you get rejuvenated you go
back another decade you don't go don't
go too far you stop taking the
antibiotic before it causes a tumor or
something really bad and you get reset
and then you wait another 20 years and
you turn it back on and you get
rejuvenated time and time again and
maybe that's the path to living for a
thousand years but for the first time in
my career I can actually see how it
would be possible to do that it's just
conjecture before whereas now this
there's an actual mechanism there's a
pathway
it wasn't even conjecture it was
insanity to think that it was possible
and anyone who would say that we could
live a thousand years was considered
crazy and I I'm on record saying that
the first person who's born today could
live to 150 and I get criticized by a
lot of people for saying that because it
sounds outrageous and I don't know if
that's true but I do know that someone
who's born today is most likely going to
make it to the year or 20 to 20 at least
and what kind of technologies will they
have that you are told you're right and
I suppose as well.if as you've suggested
today aging is a not only something
which can be paused to its current point
and kind of held where it is but can
also be reversed it means that as soon
as sufficiently sophisticated technology
becomes available everyone who is alive
at that time is potentially brought back
to wherever they need to be right and
actually the longer you live the longer
you get
live yeah yeah which is very bizarre he
thought everybody should be working on
not getting shot and not stepping out
into open traffic and not eating cake
not sitting on the couch yeah
because the longer that you live is the
potential that you'll get towards being
around when we do have this particular
solution yeah I think the number is
every year you live you get another
three months extra of life yeah it gets
kind of weird when you when you get to
technology where every year you live you
get another year to live wow that's like
the it's not done buzz numb but what's
the one that talks about processing
power doubling every three years for
computers it's the equivalent of a like
it's Moore's law best for a lifespan who
is law for human beings yeah that's
fascinating well I mean I really
appreciate your time I appreciate you
kicking Elon out so that I could come in
sit down sit down in your office
hopefully I'll be back in in you know
five years time looking at the same age
that I am now and you will be as well
and we can discuss about how far the the
research has moved from that um if any
of the listeners and I'm sure that there
will be as you've been inundated with
requests over the last few years if they
want to do some further reading or look
at some things online have you got any
resources or blogs or books that you
would recommend I do so I I tweet out
new discoveries and new things that I'm
thinking about and things that other
people have discovered so my twitter
handle is David a Sinclair noe at the
end and so that's the main way I get
daily information out but I've also
poured everything that's in my brain
into a book that's coming out later this
year in the US that's coming out in
September or early September it'll be
out in the UK and then globally
it's called lifespan the revolutionary
science of why we age and why we don't
have to I'm pretty excited about it
because it's it's gonna answer pretty
much all of the questions that people
have been asking me over the last couple
of decades that's so fascinating it must
feel I once said this I did
Podcast that was essentially me
answering a bunch of questions I get
asked all the time
will you look forward to receiving all
of the emails about how much nad should
I be taking when should I start doing it
is my testosterone out of optimal and
all that you ever need to do is just
send them one Amazon link that's like
that's the panacea answer right just
there you go read the book read the book
well that yeah it's all in the book a
plus more what I want to do with the
book is to give readers a front-row seat
on this world that I'm experiencing
every day which is blowing my mind and
making my head spin off I in terms of
the input
I tried are an answer most emails it
gets pretty hard sometimes I do also do
a LinkedIn blog so so that's a longer
format of things that I think about and
answers to questions like this I want to
do more ask me anything AMAs on reddit
too but so look for the the number of
requests I'm sure that the the people on
reddit who are currently writing nasty
comments about the fact that I can't
pronounce the words that they sent me to
give to you will be very happy to hear
that you will go and do and ask me
anything guys if you do want that don't
forget to make sure that you comment
below on YouTube or a hassle David I'm
sure that it'll have some some form of
hassle tweet him to eat him in a name
and then they'll go back on and he'll do
he'll do another ask me anything dude
it's been it's been absolutely fantastic
I really appreciate you you coming on
today and having me in your beautiful
office and I'm looking forward to the
book coming out really excited
well thanks Chris has been great to be
on him
[Music]